it's so fascinating just just like
reading your book
i'm sorry on a small tangent um
that sapiens is like
one of the most popular books in the
world
like yeah and it's reading your book
it's like
well this sounds yeah
i mean like i don't know i don't know
what makes a popular book
yeah well if you want me to be petty and
stupid i will tell you that
from time to time um we also wonder
um why our book you know
like all books people um can
take issue with it but we thought it
would be a bigger hit
that would be more widely read and it's
funny because i
i've um i don't know if i have good
examples i forgot already but i'm
often saddened by like franz kafka i
think he wasn't known
in his life yeah but i always wonder
like
these great yep like some of the
greatest books
ever written are completely unknown
during the other
lifetime and it's like man
for some reason that it's again this
that identity thing
i think oh man that sucks well i'm
comforted by that so van gogh
sold one painting in his life and
evidently uh thoreau sold like
75 copies of walden
uh nietzsche's books did not
sell well and how did ernest beck
herself
he he is the uh his books are published
by the free press
and have sold more than any other books
um that they have published so
so what does that mean it's a lot i i
don't know if it's like jordan peterson
millions but
it's hundreds of thousands was he
respected uh
i i just don't see him i okay yeah
uh i don't see him brought up as a
like in the top 10 philosophers of no
not at all so
how far away is he is he in the top 100
for people i don't think so
like he doesn't he's not brought up that
often because again like your work is
brought up more often
yeah like term like because i think it
gotten
you know yeah i mean i think he's one of
the great philosophers of the 20th
century so
what we say lex is that our goal
certainly when we first started and now
just as much actually but
what i say at all my talks is look if
these ideas have interest you enough
to go read ernest becker then this has
been good i consider him to be
one of the most important voices of the
20th century
who does not get the attention
that he deserves all right similarly
our work i believe to be important
because point by point
we provide empirical corroboration
for all of the claims if
you know when um that so that's
literally the students that
read the denial of death and then escape
from evil they're like yeah
wow every chapter of the book you have
studies
and i'm like yeah because for 40 years
if a skimmer student said oh that's got
to be
i'm like well let's do a study let's do
a study
you